for joining welcome to the rstudio
enterprise community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey actually calling in
from connecticut today
we are streaming out to linkedin and
youtube live
if you've just joined now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window and say hello
maybe where you're calling in from
for today's meetup we're joined by
sam galani founder of the sports
dataverse
the sports dataverse is a set of open
source sports data packages
that work in harmony because they share
common data representations and api
design
just a few
notes during the meetup you will be able
to ask questions
you can either put them into linkedin
where you're watching or on youtube
we also have a slido link that i'll
share in the chat so you can ask
questions anonymously as well
but uh just so you know if you do ask
questions you'll be part of the
recording as well so right when the
meetup is over the recording will be
shared to youtube which is one of the
nice things of doing it on youtube live
it's there immediately but for anybody
who is joining this meetup group for the
first time
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for teens to share use cases
teach lessons learned and
just meet each other and ask questions
so thank you all for making this a
welcoming community
together we're dedicated to providing an
inclusive and open environment for
everyone
so we want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from you all regardless of your
level of experience or area of work too
but with that thank you again for
joining us
i would love to introduce sam and pull
him
up on stage here virtually
sime galani is the director of data
science and engineering for the houston
rockets and the founder of the sports
dataverse
time thank you so much for joining us
absolutely it's a pleasure to be here i
am very grateful for the opportunity to
talk about the sports dataverse
um
and we we consider it an initiative
because
everything is
kind of in a constant state of
work in progress
to
both make
things that
make resources exist and then
maintain them to a simple standard
the topic of the conversation is
generally going to be about uh
how the sports data versus trying to
develop uh
lasting solutions for
accessing sports data
and creating analytics based on the uh
open source data we have available
and creating
public utilities for the community to
both
use and enhance
as research progresses
and so the main goals are for us to be
creating a
you know
high standard of data resources
for the sports analytics community
in addition
creating pathways to make the
uh sports analytics industry more
diverse inclusive and accessible that's
that's the primary goal here is to lower
the
standard learning curve that goes into
actually making
uh progress in
becoming a competitive candidate in the
sports analytics field
and so some of the solutions we've
brought about
are uh
building an extensive set of open source
uh sports data repositories
uh and then creating the packages to
um
load the data from python r and node
we'll be primarily focusing on the r
packages with given that this is an r
studio presentation
and establishing the bench of developers
from
diverse backgrounds to spearhead
projects and make contributions within
the um
the actual packages within the sports
dataverse
and most important well
the the second problem of this goal is
to
bring women's sports data analytics
um
research
on par with the same level of uh
resources available
um
within the public so
within the public space
uh and like
just generally make more strides to
make uh the analytic space a little bit
more equitable for both sides
um so
as rachel mentioned i'm the lead
engineer for the sports adverse i
am an ml engineer by trade
uh
i'm currently working for the houston
rockets as the director of data science
and engineering
i previously worked in health care
and medical malpractice freight freight
supply
as well as online data science course
development
and most recently i was working for
deloitte
as a consultant in
cyber security
uh
i think the
roundabout way of how i got into sports
analytics
uh the open source side anyway i've
always been into sports analytics since
uh basically i found out that they were
tracking numbers in sports but
that was uh my first
foray into it and then as i got into the
open source space
i found the need to
uh work
with college football data
for while i was uh contributing to
tomahawk nation the fsusb nation site
covering the
florida state seminoles which is where
i'm from
i'm born and raised in tallahassee
i
bleed garden gold for sure
um
and so that's how i can start
contributing to my first open source
sports project with the
mayapan tsubaya and parker fleming
cfb scraper which later became cfb fast
r
modeled after the nfl fast star and nfl
verse
so
we call it an initiative
because
it's
more a goal than it is anything else
just to bring together an incredibly
remarkable set of people who can code at
a high level
and can follow
um
standard guidelines for you know good
good good code practice
and
the kind of people that can
actually create reproducible and
durable pipelines
uh data pipelines for
the entire community to benefit from
because the idea
we all
in the sports analytics industry and any
data analytics
industry
will
will have to create
data pipelines in order to do modeling
and so
that's the first step of our
initiative is
how do we make getting sports data easy
and could we get further if we actually
built the data infrastructure together
so that we all have reproduce like
being able to validate models quicker
using standard open
um
data sets
will allow us to
create better
um
create better prototypes better that can
be easily validated
um so the sports dataverse is just
basically an organization
trying to make the
i mean the sports data versus several
things
and they're all it's a basically a
catch-all term for the community of
people that support the sports database
um
and so
we are nothing without our uh
development team
very grateful for the contributions that
everybody makes to
the packages and and data repositories
and pipelines that
that really make the entire thing run
and so
the community is
the piece that both develops the
projects
maintains it and
mentors younger developers
and
these
will hopefully in turn
turn into
future maintainers and developers of
further research and packages within
the sports dataverse and just generally
in the sports analytics domain and
broadly
and
these uh these packages all typically
operate from um
at least
the
data fetching side
of the
they typically will
have corresponding data repositories
which allow for the fast loading of our
data
at basically whatever speed like at the
limitation of your internet connection
and
available ram
we've created
one of the largest open source sports
data resources
given that it's
over uh 250 gigabytes
produced
in various formats
um
and that's just from the four or five
packages that
i or
four or five sports
slash sports leagues
that i've worked on
others have also contributed
significant uh amounts of data and
comprehensive data it's incredible to
see
um the amount of
we could fit within
the um
you have free limits
it's uh truly incredible
and so
i think the thing that makes uh
the sports dataverse relatively
more appealing beyond just having like
fast pre-scraped data
is that the
the function names
are
they follow pattern
and
they tell you where
the data is coming from
based on the function name if it's
starting with a load a build or an
update
it is using the data resources
uh created by the package developers
and if it's directly interacting with a
website
it will be
give you an indication that it's like
espn
data
nba
stats api the ncaa website
these
are all assumed to be get functions so
we
provide the the access to these
functions but they should be used
carefully using a proper
uh rests in between
be polite when you're scraping with
those functions because you're directly
interacting with a uh
open data source
and so
what makes the
sports dataverse packages
um
a bit more interesting
they're rather a bit more
um attractive than mo most uh
scraper packages is the
fact that they are backed by a packaged
package
data packet like
data repositories
which allow loading for
pre-scraped data
and so
this is a
allows for like much faster access and
also
standardized pipelines
for
both
ingest and
modeling
so you can use your starting point as
just loading from the package uh
data repositories
and then
build pipelines on top of that submit a
pull request to our data our data
repository and have your models become
part of the pipeline and
you know can be used in summaries and
you can basically create
verified open source uh models which i
think is
the next step towards uh
the next phase of the the sports
dataverse
and so
we can talk about
um
the various packages within
uh
the sports dataverse
the i'm only going to focus on a couple
just because they are uh readily
available on crayon and i also wrote
them
i have
i've actually had quite a rough weekend
uh coming back from
uh houston we just got done with the nba
draft
and i have
returned home to find that my
home pcs
are
all fried and so where i had a lot of my
presentation written but not pushed i am
uh
locked out of my i'm locked out of my pc
and so i'm having to use a
a different computer to
create i had to use it to create this uh
presentation and so i was not able to
um
follow the uh guideline i'd set in the
abstract of this presentation
of uh
um going through all the various
packages
all the various functions added to we
hoop
uh it just became a full nb
uh wnba stats api scraper
added 104 functions
and it brings it on par to every
of every
available function within
hoopar which also covers the nba stats
api
so wherever there's available data for
the wnba it will have all the functions
that
um exist
and so
this uh this is just a simple
installation from uh
cloudy r
and
let's demonstrate quickly uh
how
the
function namings
allows you for easy
um
transference of knowledge between each
of the different packages
so
the
once we load the libraries you'll notice
that
whenever
we use the load functions it'll be
load the sport league which is college
football and then play by play
and then the year and it can be a vector
of years it uh
does not care
for nfl i would highly recommend
using the nfl verse and nfl fast star
we basically
took the idea of nfl fast r in the nfl
verse and
applied it
um very successfully
to create
basically identical
frameworks for
loading
um
data from for various sports from
basically we took the idea of the nfl
verse and applied it to the college
football
nba
wnba
men's college basketball women's college
basketball
the premier hockey federation the nhl
um
is that all of them
and
with more to follow and others have
followed in this example um
the world football r by uh jason
zipkovic he
is uh also working on something very
similar to make loading easy
from uh world footballer an excellent uh
soccer package within the sports
dataverse
um and so
for men's college basketball
and women's college basketball
it's just
the same
function but you're just changing it to
men's basketball
women's basketball
and this is a
college collegiate
and then
similarly it is this simple
it does not take a
you know rocket scientist to figure out
this naming convention
i try to make it as foolproof and easily
um accessible as possible
just by if you know how one of these
[ __ ] like one of these packages works in
terms of
how their
function naming works
you will have a much easier time
understanding
what is going on in each of the
different packages
and for
the same idea for fast r hockey you load
the nhl play-by-play and you can load
the premier hockey federation
play-by-play
and
this is uh
just
honestly this is already out of it out
of date since i uh last posted it but
basically these are
a subset of the packages
uh within the sports dataverse
we have i think seven packages on crayon
right now
cfb fast star hoopbar we hoop baseball r
fast star hockey
world football r
and torvik
uh which is bart torvik
scraping his website
and i just uh i haven't even announced
but
odds api r
is also on
uh crayon
oh sport er that's the other one that i
forgot
um
we basically have
an incredible number of people to thank
as part of this initiative
the community of developers that help
you know maintain all these different
packages are extremely valuable
um
and i very much appreciate all their
help
uh
and
the sports dataverse
the front end of the sports adverse is
eventually going to look something like
a game on paper
which is a uh
which is basically using the college
football endpoints of the
of the various packages
to
generate entire stats pages
for live games
like this
and we can see there's wind probability
expected points added
uh various aggregations of the team
level
these are the basic ideas that
we can continue to develop
with uh support from the community and
driven developers
so just as an example i asked somebody
to
produce
a shiny app using
one of our packages
um the weho because i was short on time
and i wasn't going to be able to get
everything done
and so he was able to throw this
together in 16 60 minutes
a pretty
incredible
like very quick application that can be
easily adapted to others
oh here we go
while it's pulling up just wanted to
remind everyone if you want to ask
questions you can just ask them in
linkedin or youtube where you're
watching or you can use the
the slido link too i'll just put it on
the screen for a second here
um
so i see a question from a good friend
uh robert frey is asking
what currently is holding baseball are
from loading full seasons of
play-by-play data
um
there's honestly no issue with trying to
make it happen
other than
my own personal availability
that's literally it
i have so much that i'm like actively
working
on and uh
well things will fall short sort of
short if uh we don't have enough other
committed people to
just take the reins and actually make it
happen
it's not it's just a matter of uh
getting more people
familiar with the infrastructure of how
the entire organization works
we've had a lot of uh
you know difficult to navigate changes
for anybody who's been nukes as i've
been
rapidly setting up all these different
repositories and organizations
getting everybody coordinated figuring
out who actually
is a github contributor
and then
allowing them
the
space to
learn how to do it
i'm not perfect about
being a
proactive leader on every single
uh piece of this
but i'm just trying my best i promise
um
and
it's just like it's a challenge i've
been learning all this as i've been
going and it's not it's not always easy
because i i'm not that good of a
programmer i'll just be honest with you
i
didn't really learn r
until
about grad school
and that was uh only a few years back
and now i have
five
six
authorships on crayon packages
so it's it's been a
very interesting challenge to get all
this worked out
um
so somebody asked
what significant improvement do you see
or want to see to the sports of
dataverse accomplishing in the next year
so
this is an excellent question because
it's something i think about a lot and
have uh
trouble prioritizing where i want the
changes to happen most because there's
you know there's the hard goals which is
hey
can we make this model happen
and
make it reproducible and make it run
every night so that it's updated daily
but
moreover
i think my biggest goal
is
you know creating
the kind of organization open source
organization
that becomes
um
the
first stop for
um teams and companies in the sports
analytics space
who are looking for developers
and analysts and data scientists and
machine learning engineers
and everything in between
because you can clearly see
that they are making
important contributions to the actual
community and
you know
being helpful within the community
to make it better for everybody
i just want to say thank you so much for
all that you do for the community and i
see people are commenting that in the
chat as well
and a lot of love for the sports
dataverse
i didn't want to interrupt and start
asking questions if you are still um
going through parts of the presentation
but i see there are a lot that are
coming in too so you just let me know
yeah i mean i'm
i'm fine to take questions wherever
um
i honestly
i had so much planned and i have stuff i
can show you that just isn't quite ready
um but
basically the presentation i was
supposed to do today
was going to be on um building
regularized adjusted plus minus models
for the wnba
and so
there's a i would expect by version um
2.0 of we hoop
that there will be um
regularized adjustment plus minus
metrics available
for players going back
to at least 2015
um wherever we can get lineups data
it's already the data is available in
the data repository i just have to make
changes to bring it into the package
through the package functions
uh but
basically yeah the data is all there we
have it all worked out
just need to make a regularized
adjustment plus minus model and then
we are
in business which is nice that's a it's
a very um
reasonable standard
of a metric that everybody agrees is at
least
uh not noise
and so we're excited about that
um
i can pull um i'll pull a few of the
questions over that are coming over on
youtube as well
um
but i see jeff had asked
is there anything special about the
relationship between the sports
dataverse in python and r are they
effectively the same initiative
oh absolutely yeah i i trimmed down
i trimmed
i trimmed a bunch of the um
python and um node parts out of this
presentation
but there's
simultaneous efforts being made
in um
both python and node to make the
um
at the very least for the node version
the scraper pack
the scraper level functions available as
uh node functions
as well as the python having the exact
same capabilities as both loading
and scraping
with the additional benefit of it being
only one package
um
because of moduling within the package
making it a little bit more convenient
if there's only one package on the
sports database python side
and
well
i shouldn't say that there is one other
package that uh
individual contributors make
and i need to figure out a better way to
streamline
integrating other people's work on the
python side that's honestly the biggest
hang up from it becoming
just as
robust in its implementation
thank you i see keith asks a great
question over on slido
about how people can contribute
keith had said how about sports outside
of north america like european ice
hockey or rugby how can we contribute
here
uh yeah this is um
probably my own fault
given that uh
i
basically the people i've brought in for
the most part
it's like 95 north americans
and then
five percent people from around the
globe
and
that's somewhat by design somewhat by
just simple geography and not knowing
everybody in the community
and so
we uh we've been definitely
making some outreach and that's
um
just as far as specific uh
examples of non-north american sports
world football r is a
pretty
vast covering
soccer package
though
if somebody would want to make
contributions on say something like
rugby
or
um
european ice hockey
i would suggest european ice hockey
would go with fast r hockey so if you
want to
if you
we're interested on the hockey side i'm
trying to bring
sports into one package um
you know divided by like
leagues
ideally to make it a minimum number of
package names you have to remember
like i only want one hockey package i
only want one basketball package ideally
but
given the the um
if i were to combine wii hoop and hoop r
it would turn into
a
350 pack 350 function package
of just a monstrosity that i
you know i i don't want to anger brian
ripley like just to be honest
and it would be incredibly
unmaintainable very quickly uh that's
how things get taken off of cran
and it's just wiser
to
limit the scope as much as possible
uh but i'm very open to uh people
uh talking to me about uh contributing
on
non-north american sports i am very into
it i just don't have the personal
um knowledge of and like
understanding of
the various uh leagues that exist
outside of the united states and north
america
so very open to learn very open to
accept contributions
uh um like
i
this was just an idea
that
lots of people in this community have
had
and i just tried to execute it and
as i've tried to execute it i've been
like wait i need to change how i do this
every step of the way
and it's just a constant learning
process
i like for example um
jackie tran she made a very wonderful
um
women's national basketball
league
of australia women's basketball package
um
and
i did not know that league existed so
i had to um
well we have to figure out how to make
um
more
data accessible through these packages
to
give it broader coverage because i
really want there to be
equitable coverage across like women's
sports and like
not just north americans like leagues i
i focused there because i knew there was
a lot of data there
um and i
also knew what the websites were
that's uh that's basically how this
whole deal works
um
somebody's like hey we should scrape
this resource
and
somebody does it
and
we just figure out how to cobble it all
together into a useful format
awesome and and so i'm just um for
people who are interested in
contributing
is it best to go through the sports
dataverse website or through github or
what's the best way to get in touch with
people
um
both the uh like the easiest way to get
our attention is first to uh
you know
message myself on uh
simon galani
or the sports dataverse um
uh
twitter
also at sports dataverse or the cfb fast
r one if you're looking for something
college football specific
but and then as well as anybody you know
to be affiliated through the get help
organization um
start talking to us that's all that's
all it takes and you will become you
will invite you to our community
and have
um a talk about how to bring in whatever
idea you have
uh it's
i'm not super
[Music]
uh picky i
i just
i just like
we just have to talk about it and
we have to make it happen that is just
like a it's a process of
talking about it
and uh bringing together a plan and
making it make it work
that's great
um i see samurai asked a question which
i know comes up in a bunch of data
science hangouts as well
i want to pursue a career in sports
analytics what resources do you
recommend
athletics
uh
excellent book um for modeling
and uh
if you haven't read basketball on paper
by uh dean oliver
excellent uh introductory tutorial
and then uh
a very recent addition to my collection
the mid-range theory uh by seth bartnow
it i mean i i primarily focus on
basketball but there's an incredible
number of resources
uh
and just like in general football
analytics has uh come a long way
i i would start by
you know
following the introductory tutorials
from
various people in the sports dataverse
um
like in the packages like cfpfaststar
has seven eight vignettes
and a bunch of different examples about
how you can get started everybody always
puts their work out on twitter that's a
great way to get exposure
um
start putting your work out there like
you don't always have to be
uh
you know
mind-blowingly brilliant like i i just
started putting out
like logo plots i like everybody else
and then i started becoming a package
developer
and
things just kind of took off from there
until
i became
one of the people that's produced the
most open source packages
i it started somewhere i was
nowhere i started doing open source
development in
february of 2020 yeah
so like two and a half years later and
i'm now the director of data science for
an nba team i
it's
it's really just a matter of like
working hard putting your work out there
having people
see it and
know you in return like you have it's
it's one thing to know um
it's one thing who you know
it's another thing who knows you
like you have to be able to put yourself
out there in order to have like the name
recognition like oh yeah i remember this
person because of this analysis they did
an incredibly valuable way to promote
your own work and get feedback on your
work
is using twitter make analyses
like put a blog post up get some
feedback
like there's so many people who are
willing to help especially if you start
like
putting it in front of us
uh
incredibly uh
yeah i can't understate how important
that piece of this is that we don't talk
about enough
i love that just start sharing your work
um i see there's quite a few other
questions coming in from
linkedin and youtube
one is
what are some of the plug and play
analysis or functions that these
packages have
oh uh so basically
uh
the probably the most developed one is
uh cfb fast star
because we
that was initially
um
modeled after after
uh nfl scrap scraper
uh written by ron yerko sam ventura and
uh maxim horowitz
uh
which uh in turn
was part of the
open war uh
nfl paper
which i highly recommend reading
um
basically
you can
add pipelines
to
any of the existing play-by-play
functions
to
get um
you know various levels of expected
points added and when probability
metrics
not all the packages have them
uh
basically
i would
the presentation today was actually
supposed to be me developing a new
metric for a women's college or women's
uh
national basketball association
um
because that's basically the next phase
of this a lot of it is data get
functions um
or
data get and then compiled into a
loadable data set but the goal
is for people to
um
create pipelines on top of it
and then submit those pipelines to us to
incorporate into our data repositories
and then
in turn be made available
to end users um through the package
functions
and so like that's that's really where
the next part piece of this goes a lot
of them
a lot of the packages fall into
one of three categories
not all of which exist yet
there's the data scraping
which is uh basically all of them right
now but uh there's modeling uh packages
which may just store models or you know
methods to create models
and then there's data visualization um
packages like uh cfb platar or
um
mlb plot r
or sporty r uh which create allow you to
create um
very useful visualizations
or uh tables
depending
um
on what your
goal is
but
the
real
the real deal thing that i want to see
get started in the next phase of the
sports anniversary beyond just us like
covering more sports and sports leagues
i want us to take the next step of
incorporating other people's models
that they want to contribute
um
to the open source space so that they
can become
like a standardized method that
everybody can reference like hey
you know this person made a um
an adjusted plus minus model
and it takes these certain things into
effect we can document it
and then
you add it to
our nightly data repository load for
that sport league
however
um
the pipeline works and then it's made
available for users on
you know every time
we run the nightly loads
thank you
i see
i know we touched upon this already but
i see a lot of the questions
coming in are focused around
like tips for shifting into the space of
sports analytics as well but do you have
any specific tips for shifting from a
different industry into sports
um
so yeah i guess i should probably tell
you a little bit more about myself
i um
i was in healthcare analytics and on the
actuarial side
uh
and um in medical malpractice briefly
just like as an analyst where i wound up
using a lot of excel vba
sql and sas
and
learning sql helped me a great deal sas
is very useful as well
um
but given that it's a paid software
i think uh
not
the most useful in this space given that
so many of the data science solutions um
you know are
using open source software
so i wound up getting a um
getting some hands-on experience while i
was working for startups in
python and r
modeling
and that was very useful and um
in turn getting into grad school
because that's where i went to uh
georgia tech
uh their online master and analytics
program
very exceptional program very uh
affordable
and i learned a great deal of
various programming methods languages
techniques frameworks
um
as well as the math behind it which is
an exceptionally
um
valuable piece to
my understanding of how
everything works in in stats
like because you have to have both like
you need to work on your programming
skills and like just your breadth of
understanding of how different pieces in
the stack fit together
and being able to
manipulate data in those frameworks or
languages
and then
being able to uh
understand the stats and math that are
useful
for your data sets like being able to
understand what your data is telling you
what it can do what it can't do
as far as building models that are
useful
is
the
that's that's like the bread and butter
of how you become a valuable data
scientist
thank you
i see that there are a lot of people
commenting in the chat or asking if
other people from the community are
interested in working with certain
sports data like volleyball data for
example
and so i did just want to take a second
to
call out that this channel exists
so that on the r for data science online
learning slack community
there's a channel called chat sports
analytics
but i thought it could be a good place
for people to connect even after
the meetup too
so just wanted to leave that up there
that's the link to join just r for ds
dot io slash join
and the specific channel itself is the
one in blue there
you assume
we actually do have a uh
a private discord that we invite people
to
in spite of our like um
you know open and accessible
uh
mantra
we try to keep the
conversation to people who are actually
trying to help with the packages so we
don't have a fully open uh
community
as far as like talking to us every
single day and working on packages
directly with us
but it's not super hard to get an invite
as long as you're about it
you just have to talk to me about it
show me your github and that's pretty
much
it awesome so reach out on the sports
dataverse twitter right yes um
awesome
um this isn't really a question but i
really loved this comment the anonymous
comment on slido was this is the truest
demonstration of you don't need to be
the most like elite programmer or do it
all alone to make a really useful
package so thanks for for sharing that
too
i appreciate that because a lot of days
i'm just like wow
i can't believe anything i write works
and like people find it useful all right
fantastic
um but it's true you really don't have
to be you know
elite to make a difference
you know because as long as you ex you
try and execute an idea doesn't matter
if your code is always the fastest it's
nice if it is
but
if you're just trying to get a job done
and make it durable
sometimes that's speed is not always the
answer
a few other questions that are coming
through is um
one is
are any of those packages are they
providing real-time data or is it just
batch mode after every single game is
over
uh
i believe pretty much all of them
are
all of the r packages have a
interface directly to the
website source that they
pull the loaded data from so basically
what we wind up doing
is uh the data repositories essentially
work
that we scrape data from
one of the websites that's included
within the uh package usually
uh i think the minimum standard is we
usually have an espn
for uh
version of the play-by-play player box
and team boxes
um
and that's compiled at the season level
uh and so that is usually done through
um
package functions and like we just run
it every single night
uh to make sure it's updated with the
most recent data and so they
if as long as it's available on their
website live then it's available through
the package live
if that makes sense
because we're almost always in directly
interacting with their apis as they're
live
great thank you
um i also just wanted to take a second
in this platform to share that i know
the women and sports data symposium is
coming up to
on august 20th
and i just put the twitter
account to the symposium there that you
can follow if you're interested in
getting involved as well
very like we are highly supportive of
them
um
uh they are doing excellent things it's
going to be a fantastic conference
please attend
uh
and we are happy to uh
discuss sponsoring if you need help
getting there
that's great yeah it looks amazing
um so a few other questions i myself am
not sure exactly what this question
means but
what would uh be your opinion about
dfts density functional theory as an
application
i'm not sure
if that relates to a specific package or
not so i just wanted to ask it okay
we can see we can save that one and if
anyone has some thoughts on it feel free
to to share it in the um
the chat too
uh
so basically um
i see this question from rodrigo from
youtube uh is sports editors focused
only on providing access to oh wait we
we did cover some of this
um
it would be helpful if anybody wants to
make like
useful reporting
that they would like to be run every
night
um
we are always willing to accept that
sort of stuff especially
if it's um
something that can be updated every
night that'd be good
yep
[Music]
let me um jump over to the slido too and
just a
reminder if you did want to ask any
anonymous questions you can put them
there on on slido as well i'll just put
the link up
again
and sorry i'm a little over the place
trying to get them from youtube and
linkedin and slido all at once but i
think
covered the majority of
the questions
um
someone had asked about
some of those books that you
had recommended
do you know if any of them are available
like
in online
free versions as well kind of like how
the r for data science book is
i cannot say that i do
i
also
really like the people who have made
these books so i would not uh
i would encourage you to support them if
you can um
but i honestly don't know of any uh free
versions yeah it's worth checking out um
um
constantine knows uh pelicrinus is a
sports
uh analytics
coursework that he's provided because
i'm sure he's provided a bunch of
excerpts for
from the book
during those course notes and lectures
great thank you
one other question was could this
package be utilized for prediction
purposes
um
i'm assuming you're talking about a
specific package but in theory that's
exactly what all these are for
um
right now they're mostly uh just pulling
in data as it comes from websites
and there's not much being done
to enhance it i'm just trying to get the
data in just going
uh and made available
so that you the user and like
contributor potential contributor to the
sports dataverse could then
build a pipeline and be like hey
if you run these two functions
you can get this set of reporting and
modeling done
um
here's how you would train that model
here's a proof of concept of how it
works
please add it and you know you make a
pull request to us
or just talk to us about it how you
would get it incorporated to
the
broader community and package
and that's
that's that's the next phase we want
that
please muted sorry eugene i see um had
asked it looks like you have quite the
trophy cabinet behind you sign
which are your sports
math
oh like
matt yeah
100
love it
another question i realized i had missed
from earlier is what are some newer
aspects of data analytics in the mba
that excite you
well there's a lot more stat companies
now that are providing nba
data
um
and that's uh always an exciting
opportunity to like
learn from
i like get a get a check on yourself
from you know various other uh very
smart analysts in the field uh
which is great
as well as like there's actual
opportunities for new data that's being
provided to us from existing providers
um
whether it be raw tracking data from
either second spectrum or um
zealous
using spec and spectrum's data um
stats reform there's a bunch of people
that are providing more and more
interesting data
that
you have to become
adept at building these pipelines
because that's the work you have to do
like
the entire purpose of
why i think this is a very good route
for people to learn
the skills they absolutely need on the
job
for working in sports analytics is
you're going to get new data sources
you're going to have to build data
pipelines you need to be able to do it
fast
and
you got to make them durable make sure
they don't break and learn how to make
them
basically work no matter what
um
and so that
that means working with tracking data
from you know
whether it be
provided to you or creating your own
tracking data using computer vision
model modeling
um
and extracting you know coordinate
systems
just like learning how to work with very
large data sets
is uh
the name of the game
because
at the end of the day
you're
you're going to be working with
continuously bigger data sets the more
data you are provided
i just want to say if i have missed
anyone's question
feel free to add it into the chat again
just to make sure that i see it here i
know we're getting to the top of the
hour but want to make sure i didn't miss
any
oh yeah um
just on the uh
the baseball r side
the person
who actually taught me the most about
uh both baseball
and uh
working with r
is robert fray who asked the first
question at the top of the hour
um
his youtube channel was actually very
instrumental for me learning how to
uh build a scraper package
because he shows you an incredible in
incredible amounts of detail how to go
about doing it and i i would highly
recommend it you posted his um
youtube page in the in the chat that's i
literally
incorporated his work into um baseball r
and
i learned it from watching his youtube
page and i became a co-author of
baseball as a result it's just like a
crazy
uh roundabout way of like
taking someone else's idea
making it more functional
and
you know
being recognized for that
like making like
uh concrete contributions to the open
source uh community
it's just like little ideas like that
will
um
make you
beloved to me at least
i would appreciate it
that's great and i i put it on the
screen here but it doesn't let you click
so
um if anyone wants to copy and paste
from the chat and re-share or robert you
want to share again that would be really
helpful too
let's see just give me a second here to
scroll through and see if there are
other questions that we miss as well
um
i do also want to just say if
people are going to be at the r studio
conference
later in july we will have a birds of a
feather group
for sports analytics community as well
so it might be great to
meet some people there and and connect
ahead of that too
uh let's see any other
questions you see
oh one other one
i see austin just asked how do you get
your team to align and follow with your
metrics
any challenges there or
are teams senior leaders more aligned
with data analytics lately
well
i work in the best place for that like
in the nba at least like
analytics and data scientists are highly
respected in our organization
they are always asking about modeling
and i think
it's
incredible that
this level of understanding
exists throughout the organization it's
not just at the top it's
even scouts are asking about the
different like statistical techniques
and modeling
because they're incorporating it
as like
shortcuts to what they know to look for
and you continuously get more and more
benefits from
actually
um
having a top-down understanding within
your organization
about uh
analytics and metrics like what's useful
what's not
it like make it cuts down your search
time on you know your search time to
insight by
an incredible amount it's just it's
so very useful and everybody should be
doing it and i'm very grateful to be in
a place where it is respected and
understood as valuable
uh
it's
yeah you can't exist without it anymore
um you're just giving up too much of an
advantage
okay i know we're a minute over so i
think we have time for
one or two more questions if that's okay
but also just want to let people know if
you're on and listening and you're
hiring
in the sports industry or actually in
any
industry and want to share your role in
the chat feel free to do so um that's
perfectly okay as well
um but the other question was from jeff
it said
great question
in your opinion is sports analytics
community stronger in r or python
so
the
open source community is a lot stronger
and are
in part because of the excellent example
set by
you know people like tan ho
uh and and sebastian carl of the nfl
verse ben baldwin
and t and and you know tash seth
people who are making all these
tutorials using nfl verse data
and
as a result there's an incredible
um
level of knowledge of r within the
open source community
at least like and especially it's very
public on twitter
um
and so that that that might be
part of what's influencing my opinion on
this
but
the industry
is uh very much into python
because work like more often than not
it's already existing it within their
pipelines
and more people
that
more people that build applications are
more familiar with uh
with python rather than r
just because they're usually not
building shiny applications
uh for
you know internal websites
uh where they're displaying analytics
and so that usually
um
necessitates or
you know gives somewhat of a uh
preference to python
because you can easily they already can
build they already know how to build the
api apis using those functions in in
python but there's no reason you can't
use it at the definitely at the team
level or even
at the um
you know the stats company level for uh
python as long as it's not being uh
you know leveraged more than you know
several hundred times a second
uh and so
you could definitely it's very helpful
to know both actually like i can't say
uh enough about
part of the reason i was a valuable
candidate was because i knew both
and
being being flexible is
is a
very useful trait as your team gets
smaller
knowing knowing a little bit of
everything is very valuable
but uh if you
if you have a cs background
i would say you probably need a lot less
r
but
if you're
if you're coming from any background
that isn't just purely cs
i would suggest like learning r first
because it's a little bit easier
um the learning curve is not that strong
and there's tons of examples out there
that's the other thing is like
you have just
loads of open code from you know useful
developers around here uh who just are
very generous with their time and
efforts and will show you like the
community
of our our
the our our community is excellent the
people are the most helpful i've ever
seen and you can get to know them very
quickly like
it's not that big of a group
and so you learn
like who can actually help me with this
problem and you
latch onto those people and it's like
hey you are my friend now
this is this is how it works
i love that
well i have one more question i want to
make sure we get to as well um and i see
this was asked over on slido keith asked
regarding players or teams following
metrics what is the percentage split of
data consumed during the game versus
outside the game
i i'm not gonna answer that like as a
percentage but
by far there's much more done
um
there's much more done after the game or
like outside of the game because
you only have you only have the
bandwidth to focus on so many things
during the game especially if you're
like trying to communicate it
to
uh like the coaching staff
so that makes you know
limiting the amount of noise you intake
during a game to only the most useful
things that they can
uh immediately
make a decision on or are like expecting
a uh response on like hey
should we foul here yes or no
and what's our best strategy
in like this time frame
margin
uh that sort of stuff
but it's not like they're looking at a
you know an individual's plus minus
during the game
uh
it's like oh yeah we need to get him out
of here he's a minus seven no no that's
not a thing
well thank you so much time for your
presentation and just being so open and
honest with everyone and answering all
these questions
this was great
i appreciate all the the awesome
questions in the chat as well whether
you're watching on linkedin or youtube
really appreciate everyone's time
i wanted to put the sports data versus
twitter up on the screen just one more
time if people are interested in
collaborating or want to reach out
and i would also recommend checking out
our github organization
uh github.com sports diverse
because that's where you can see the
actual developers who are involved and
other people whose work you can check
out be like oh that's an awesome idea
let me see if i can make that hap like i
can recreate that
um
because that's that's the best way i
both
meet people i want to meet and uh
learn things i didn't know like
i religiously follow
people's githubs
i that is my primary form of social
media i actually don't like twitter that
much i don't post that much but i am
definitely following you on github
like
and that's that's where i learn
so many new things that other people are
working on it's just a great way to pick
up
it's a great way to stay uh
up to date on various techniques
and like methodologies and
just interesting ideas
please do it
good for you
perfect i just shared it in the chat as
well as on the screen here too
but just want to say thank you again
simon i know you had uh
a lot of technical stuff going on with
the computer as well this week too so
thank you for still joining us today
um really yeah i would love to come back
and uh
show you all how to do
i'll i'll very least make a blog post
about it but uh
because making
some uh very unique women's basketball
uh
models would be
an exceptional contribution that i would
hope we could all do together it'd be
great i would very much uh love to do
that but if not
it has been excellent
thank you so much for all you do for the
sports community too
have a great rest of the day everybody
my pleasure